[Music]
[Applause]
we're already on week seven of the mass
simmer and this garden is shrinking by
the minute when it comes to the flower
things have officially wilted hi guys
I'm Deidre Behar and I'm Charley
O'Keeffe but first we have a very
special guest with us tonight straight
from the stage of the masked singer and
his producer Bryan Strickland Wow I'm so
honored to be here I'm a little
emotionally exhausted from that episode
it was a lot but we're expecting you to
spill a lot of tea right here I'll do it
I'll do it
and now despite many performances being
in full bloom sadly there are no more
petals to pick off the flower watch this
miss patty Wow straight from Walmart's
we are such big Patti LaBelle fans it
was so cool to see her do the masked
singer so we obviously wanted to
celebrate her victorious run on the show
with all of her you know this whole
smorgasbord right here we dress sweet
potatoes they're incredible and I we
plan on eating me are you shocked are
you surprised we knew it I've been
calling this one since day one I mean
that voice is just so recognizable and
iconic I have been saying Patti from the
start never Macy Gray look I'm gonna
give Charlie credit where it's due
he always champion that this was Patti
LaBelle I'm sort of like looking at all
the clues and kind of piecing it all
together towards the end of of her run
on the show it got more and more obvious
things like perfume the guys playing
patty-cake and the dominoes that spelled
out that wrote 1944 the year that she
was born I was pointing to Patti so you
were surprised you weren't surprised
that it was Patti but were you surprised
that she got a match yes I am I think I
wanted to see more of her I liked her on
the show we haven't heard her do
something like this in a while so it was
definitely different but there's a
there's a few other big names on there
under there I think that are gonna be
unmasked I think the most interesting
thing about this is that this woman
flat-out denied that she was on the map
singer with Andy Cohen take a look
everyone says you're the flower on the
mast singer I promise you everybody well
they said it was to be last year oh
really yeah who was the bee was Gladys
yeah was glad ya know if Gladys did it
last year he kinda makes sense she would
have maybe opened the door for someone
of your caliber oh man I gotta be under
a mask in suffocate no way the way it
looked
now you may remember a few weeks ago we
showed you another masked singer and
denial from Adrienne Houghton of the
real but here we are about to take a
look at her or the Flamingo shake her
tail feather to another iconic Bob
[Music]
those vocals I mean this show has some
damn good singers yeah I mean can you
tell us can you confirm are you saying
there's seven remaining singers laughs
yes and the fact that Miss Patti LaBelle
was on mass today suppose she says
something there's some big voices so we
have said Adrienne Bailon Houghton from
the absolute beginning that voice is
super super recognizable let's talk
about tonight's clue package she
referenced the Eiffel Tower which we all
know Adrian loves Paris she actually got
married there and I also being Hispanic
myself I love that she's Hispanic and
she always peppers in a little bit of
Spanish jargon into her glue packages
tonight we heard IPOs mio what did you
pick up on listen I am a Cheetah Girls
Stan yeah I love the Cheetah Girls and
we saw the Taj Mahal which could have
been a reference to Cheetah Girls 1
world which is when they traveled to
India to be in a Bollywood film we also
saw her hold up cut out of 4 paper
people 4 people could allude to these
four Cheetah Girls the original group
and also her four co-hosts on the real
Jillian Michaels the Joe McGill's Joe
Michaels is a trainer I don't know her
to be vocal she does those vocals I want
an album
Julia Michael have me all I'm saying is
expect the unexpected you never know who
it could be
Fantasia has been mentioned there's a
lot of people are Katina well I think
another thing that's so cool about this
show is that we not only get to see cool
talent we get to see really emotional
stories and I got a little choked up
watching the Flamingo talk about how
confidence has never been her thing this
show has really kind of elevated her and
brought her back to that place we
actually talked to Adrienne Bailon
earlier this year and she opened up
about how her character and the Cheetah
Girls is different from her and how it
all relates back to confidence
take a look different from me I think
she probably would have had like a solo
career I think she was very confident
she was a lot more confident than I am
in real life and I would say
may be a fashion designer as well where
yeah a little Adrien sprinkled in there
a little bit just a little so I mean
someone as poised and on television
every day like Adrienne Bailon she still
struggles with confidence I think it's
really relatable and wonderful to see I
mean what do you think I don't know how
I mean I'm not saying a word who I don't
know we think it's Adrienne doesn't she
like a host every morning on that show I
don't know well yeah she doesn't say see
they shoot that in New York I don't know
so the fact that she hasn't say maybe in
a while she probably felt a little rusty
and getting to not only be on the mass
singer but gets such praise and acclaim
from the judges in the audience has got
to feel good I mean Lady Marmalade
whoever's it was yeah was amazed Jenny
with Jenny's favorite of the year all
right guys it's me I'm back here again
your rating president of the seal fan
club I am still convinced that he is the
leopard take a listen I rest my case
it's weird
you are the biggest fan
correct what was pointing to seal here
for you so many things if you are a seal
fan you know all these things too he
referenced Paris and catwalks and so I
start thinking well this could
definitely be an allusion to his ex-wife
Heidi Klum who is a huge supermodel and
not only that seal has actually
performed on catwalks before he
performed at the Victoria's Secret
Fashion Show as Heidi Klum strutted down
the runway also relating back to Paris
he put out a whole live album called
live in Paris yeah the Australian flag
is what got it for me this one he was
actually a judge who turned the chair
around every season for seasons 1 and 2
of the voice Australia right and I think
that's a very clever red herring they
were trying to throw at us because Steel
is British so I think people were maybe
or I was at least initially a little
throw and I was like wait Australian
flag but then I was like yes the voice
and his vocal clue that we heard his
little ones will be shocked when they
find out it's him he has four kids ages
10 12 14 and 15 teenagers make sense
they're definitely watching and they
they would be shocked if it was him you
have to keep it a secret from your kids
right I don't I mean I allow people
think it's a RuPaul he's mother rube
really right I think Joel McHale baby
onto something Alec Baldwin he's got me
of like 12
[Laughter]
sounds like a lobotomy Oh does it yes
interesting I want to talk about the
clue that was a bat and we used in a
previous week in his clue package heavy
hitter and so I'm like what does this
mean baseball it's not baseball it's the
Batman movie steel had a song on the
soundtrack to Batman Forever it's the
iconic kiss from a rose take a listen
[Music]
all I know is alec baldwin's taking some
bats to some paparazzi that is true to
be Alan Ball and listen I don't know
about you but I would certainly catch a
grenade for this next performer take a
look at the Rottweiler
but she won't do the search
okay who would you catch a grenade for
Chris Daughtry yeah we're still in
agreement we've we've said Chris
Daughtry since week one
again these vocalists have such distinct
unique sounding voices but if you don't
even want to buy the whole like vocal of
it all we can take a look at the clue
package the facts speak for themselves
I mean we've got Chris wearing this
whole Rottweiler costume well if you're
a fan of Daughtry and you follow him on
Instagram he's actually already worn a
dog head costume it's him wearing this
like husky and I feel like those
parallels are just a little too similar
right a dog on the masked singer right I
don't know there's Clay Aiken Ruben
Studdard there's a lot of Idol band it
could be I mean yeah Darren Criss
somebody they mentioned Darren Criss I
mean why do you think it's dog track
before Awards this one's kind of a sound
award
like a sad clue in a way but we saw four
Awards well Chris Daughtry actually has
had four nominations four Grammy Awards
that has not taken one home those could
be pointing to the awards he should have
won or could've won but didn't
well that's why he's going for that mess
in your own the other thing that really
kind of caught my attention was 1226 is
boxing day so I was like oh is it does
it have to do with his like really
healthy lifestyle well actually
boxing day 1226 that's Chris's birthday
he's a December 26th baby
so all of this evidence I think kind of
settles our case there was one more clue
that got me though we saw September
circled on a calendar right what was
this has a song called September take a
listen
[Music]
Brian Billie Joe Armstrong I don't know
I mean I honestly I don't know Wow well
you did throw out of a lot of good names
but it's getting harder every single
week to steer us in the other direction
we're so set in our ways before we wrap
up though we do have some burning
questions for you we like an answer can
you give us a clue for the rest of this
season there's still seven singers in
there can you just tell us what you can
say
I think the order of the unmasking is
gonna be sort of shocking I think if you
have an idea of who the finals may be
it's probably very different from that
meaning who we think is a true
frontrunner absolutely yeah an underdog
may surpass people that you I mean again
like I said with Patti LaBelle as the
flower like when she was I'm asked
tonight yes anything can happen and now
one more thing yeah we see a lot of fun
moments with the judges on there what
are we not seeing that happens on well I
will tell you one thing flower loved
Ken's Bjork I heard that all the
performance producers told me that she
thought that was the funniest thing ever
that she could possibly she loved the
Bjork on that okay can you tell us
something behind the scenes II about the
judges what goes on during commercial
breaks are they trading notes are they
they are wonderful people I work with
all four of them and I love them
all very much like my childre I know
right
Nicole and Ken or like brother and
sister those two were like so funny
together
Joel McHale is gonna be back next week
as a guest judge that's exciting and
then t-pain is coming on and he's
actually really really funny I did not
really get where his guesses he's got
some interesting you know because he
comes from the and it's the first time
we hear from somebody who's actually
been on the other side so this
perspective is actually really really
interesting and is it true that you're
already in the middle of season 3 are
you filming
pre-production no filming is bad yet all
I can say about it is because like Kelly
Osbourne said last week those NDA's are
no joke I will have to move back to
Tennessee all I will say is we premiere
on this after this
yeah and it it's deserving of that times
like it's bigger and better and is there
anyone that you would love to see on
season 13 that's a good question
there's three people okay that's here I
would love Jessica Simpson I also think
Cher
although like Patti LaBelle her voice is
so iconic you may know and I would love
to see somebody that we're not we're not
we don't think of as a singer somebody's
look it's an actor who has an incredible
voice yeah something like Jake
Gyllenhaal I don't remember if you
remember his SNL hosting where he he's
an amazing voice I'm sure Jake
Gyllenhaal would love to be on the mass
singer I would love to be out there yeah
Maggie Gyllenhaal if you're watching
tell your brother to be on the master
all right my last question are you going
into season three how are you raising
the stakes how is it gonna be different
what's the Super Bowl season so it's all
about the essence more singers more
surprises Oh more shock
boilers more everything it's gonna be
really really great you guys so we're
gonna explode every week I love it with
Miss Patti LaBelle gone there's one less
singer going for that top spot we'll be
back after Thanksgiving for the next
episode diving deeper into clue packages
and performances and as usual don't
forget to post your comments below and
tweet us who you think the remaining
celebrities are and let us know who you
think could make it to the finale I'm at
Charles E O'Keefe and am at Deidre Behar
Happy Thanksgiving we love you we'll see
you next time all the pie perfect
Thanksgiving meal buttermilk pie Queen
[Music]